sabemos que una función es algo que toma
un conjunto de números y para cada uno
de los números del conjunto nos va a
relacionar con otro conjunto de números
si yo tengo un conjunto de números que
voy a poner aquí en esta tablita bajo la
x el conjunto de números que puedo poner
en la función o el conjunto de números
para los cuales está definida la función
que como vimos antes se le llama dominio
vamos a probar diferentes valores en el
dominio esta gráfica de aquí nos ayuda a
ver el dominio de la función si x es
igual a 0 qué valor toma esta gráfica
cuando x es igual a cero efe x
fx va a ser igual a menos 8 tomamos al 0
como entrada y lo relacionó con el menos
8 ahora si tomamos como entrada 2 que lo
va a relacionar la función fx es menos 6
y qué tal si x fuera menos 2 pues
también lo relacionaría con el menos 6 y
bueno todo esto está muy bien para una
función ya que si ingresamos un valor en
la función y obtenemos como resultado
otro valor tenemos una función legítima
podemos tener dos entradas relacionadas
con el mismo valor de salida como lo
vemos aquí otra forma de verlo es que
tenemos el dominio aquí y el rango acá
el dominio tiene todas las entradas
válidas de la función el rango lo vemos
como la imagen el conjunto de todas las
salidas válidas de nuestra función para
cada una de las entradas válidas dominio
y este es el rango lo que tenemos aquí
es que el 2 se relaciona con el menos 6
y que el -2 también se relaciona con el
-6 lo que está muy bien para una función
tendríamos un problema si en el dominio
este 2 llevará al menos 6 pero también
relacionada a otro valor por ejemplo al
entonces ya no tendríamos una función
donde tengamos dos posibles salidas para
una entrada no va a ser función pero no
es lo que tenemos aquí tenemos aquí una
función para asegurarnos o para
comprobar que una gráfica es una función
tenemos la prueba de la línea vertical
si se dibuja una línea vertical y si la
gráfica toca esta línea vertical en sólo
un punto en todo su dominio entonces es
una función
la siguiente pregunta es se puede
invertir para que una función se puede
invertir debemos encontrar una función
que haga la relación en sentido
contrario así que deberíamos poder tomar
lo que llamaré y que es igual a fx y
deberíamos poder tomar uno de estos y
aplicarle la función inversa
efe - uno de iu y obtener la equis que
nos daría está allí
x igual a efe inversa de y por lo que lo
relaciona en sentido contrario de qué
hablamos si yo tengo como entrada menos
ocho tendré un cero como salida si la
función va de cero a menos ocho la
función inversa irá de menos ocho a cero
por eso es inversa
voy a indicarlo aquí efe inversa de
menos 8 es igual a 0 pero comenzamos a
notar algo interesante ya que la función
inversa tiene que ser una función por
derecho propio si decimos cuál será la
función inversa de menos 6 pues tenemos
dos valores relacionados con menos 6 2 y
menos 2 así que la función inversa sería
2 o menos 2
bueno pues con esto ya no tenemos una
función si con una entrada tenemos
varias salidas entonces no tenemos una
función cuando vean una función que
tenga dos o más entradas diferentes que
relacionan el mismo valor de salida
entonces no podremos tener una función
que se pueda invertir por lo que esta
función como está definida aquí no se
puede invertir así que lo escribimos no
se puede invertir y por qué no porque
tenemos dos valores que relacionan el
mismo valor y no sólo una vez sucede
muchas veces como aquí dos y menos dos
llevan a menos seis
tres y menos tres aquí los marcamos y
llevan al mismo valor
y así sucede una y otra vez quizá se
estén dando cuenta de que existe una
prueba para saber si una función puede
invertirse o no y esta es la prueba de
la línea horizontal que es similar a la
de la línea vertical la prueba de la
línea horizontal nos sirve para saber si
se puede invertir y aquí claramente
vemos que no la está cumpliendo ya que
cuando dibujamos la línea horizontal
la gráfica toca a esta línea horizontal
en dos lugares tenemos varias equis para
la misma fx esta es la gráfica de igual
a fx y hay equis que llevan a la misma
así que cuando tratamos de invertir la
tendremos una se que relaciona a dos
valores de x por lo que la invertida no
será una función
lo que nos lleva a la pregunta podremos
restringir la función o su dominio para
que esta función puede invertirse
restringirla de manera que pase a esta
prueba de la línea horizontal bueno una
forma en la que podemos restringir la
función es limitar la a los dos
cuadrantes de la derecha oa los dos
cuadrantes de la izquierda por ejemplo
si restringimos el dominio de 0 a
infinito
entonces lo que nos queda de la función
será esta parte de aquí y si sólo
tenemos un lado de esta función entonces
pasa la prueba de la línea horizontal
pues tendríamos una relación uno a uno
cada valor de iu está relacionado a un
solo valor de x podremos restringir el
rango de la función de menos infinito a
cero o quizás también de menos tres a
menos dos y sólo veríamos esta parte de
la función lo que pasaría la prueba de
la línea horizontal y la de la línea
vertical por lo que sería invertido
espero que esto les haya ayudado a
comprender lo que significa invertir una
función y las formas que tenemos para
probar si una función se puede invertir
y también cómo hacer que es una función
se puede invertir restringiendo el
dominio y hacer que una función no
invertible se pueda invertir